Okay. So on that verse,
I think uh correct me if I'm wrong, but
they realized it because he said, "God
is working on this day and so am I." So
he compared himself right there to God.
And then he said that um if I remember
the verse correctly that he was he
called God his father
>> making himself equal to God. Meaning
that since the father has every right to
work on the Sabbath not stop being the
son he has that same authority that God
does to work on the Sabbath which is not
true for anyone else. In other words,
the point is no Jew can work on the
Sabbath. But God is exempt because God
must con constantly and continue to work
on every day because if he stops working
on the Sabbath, who's going to sustain
the universe?
>> Yeah. And in that verse, I would say
it's real. It's specific, too, because
you could just say, "Oh, we're awesome
to God." But no, he likened himself to
God on the Sabbath working that he does,
too.
>> Yeah. to that.
>> How does that to God the Father?
>> Cuz you pretended to get it, then I gave
you the answer and you're still
confused. So, how does that prove that
he was making himself equal to God the
Father?
>> Because he's working just as God works
to substain creation.
>> So, how does that show equality? Explain
it to me. Be
>> because how does Okay, I'm sorry. You're
going to have to explain that part
because I thought that was the answer.
>> No. Working on the Sabbath. Okay. How
does that show that he's claiming to be
equal to the father?
>> Uh I would say because he likened
himself to God. So just like my uh
>> So how does that
to God? I still don't get the answer.
You're just repeating what it says.
>> I'm sorry. You're going to have to tell
me. I'm sorry. Even though I explained
it, but you're too excited to hear
yourself. My goodness. And then verso
says, "I'm rude for."
Did you hear what I just said? I just
said, "If you're a Jew under the
covenant,
>> Mhm.
>> are you exempt from observing the
Sabbath or you're bound to observe the
Sabbath?"
>> You're bound to it.
>> Is God the Father bound to keep the
Sabbath?
>> No.
>> Why?
>> Because he created it.
>> Okay. So, he created it. Why isn't he
subject to it?
>> Why?
>> Because I mean God is subject to no one
and nothing I would say.
>> You sure about that? Because it says
that God cannot deny himself because he
has to be faithful to himself to his
nature. So why is God exempt from
working on the Sabbath?
>> Because he has to work to substain
creation.
>> You got it. So God were to take a break
on the Sabbath, there goes creation,
right?
>> Of course. Yeah. So the Jews knew
because God Almighty sustains every part
of creation and preserves every part of
creation, he cannot stop actively
sustaining creation or there goes
creation. No one would exist, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So he has no choice but to work on the
Sabbath.
But that's true of only God, right?
Creatures don't need to work on the
Sabbath. So they're subject to the
Sabbath, right?
>> Yes, of course.
So when Jesus says, "My father's
working, I too am working." Meaning
because I am his son and I'm one with
him, I have the same right and the same
authority to work on every day of the
week, even Sabbath that he has. Because
like my father, I am free from Sabbath
restriction. Because like my father, I
am personally actively sustaining
creation with him every day, every
second of the week. That's how they knew
he was claiming to be equal because no
one but God is free from Sabbath
observance because God must actively be
working on the Sabbath and every second
continually to keep creation going. But
if Jesus is a mere creature, then he
does not have that freedom. But as a
Jew, he's bound to the Sabbath. But his
point is, no, I'm his son in a unique
way, in a special way, which makes me
one with him, which authorizes me to do
whatever he does whenever he does it on
any day he does it because we're always
working together.
That's how they knew he was claiming to
be equal.
>> You understand?
>> Yes, sir. It's beautiful.
>> Everyone got it? You understand how he
said like my father is exempt from the
Sabbath. I his son
one with him,
same authority that he has,
have the same right that he has to work
on the Sabbath because
I am the son who always does what the
father does in the same way he does it.
So when he acts, I act. When he moves, I
move because I am the unique son who has
the same authority of the father over
Sabbath.
But that's something no creature can
claim that. And he says it right here.
Jesus gave them this answer. Very truly
I say to you, truly I tell you, the son
can do nothing by himself. He can only
do he can do only what he sees his
father doing. Because whatever the
father does, the son also does. Now let
me explain how this proves he's not a
creature. No creature can say I can only
do what God does. Nothing more, nothing
less. Can a creature say that?
>> Not at all.
No creature can say, "I do whatever God
does in the same way that God does it."
Right?
>> Yes.
>> But Jesus just said, "I can only do what
the Father does and tells me to do, no
more, no less, because I'm inseparable
from him. And I always do what the
Father does in the same way he does it."
So when my father acts, I act and the
spirit acts. When my father works, I'm
working because we always work together
and cannot do otherwise. So he can't act
and I remain inactive because as a son
who's one with him, I'm always actively
working with him, side by side,
alongside of him because that's all I
can do and that's
all that I do.
So the only time I can stop working on
the Sabbath is when my father stops
working on the Sabbath. Because I can
only work
and only act in perfect union with him.
So when he acts, I act and I can't do
otherwise but act and work when he acts
and works because of their inseparable
union.
You understand?
>> Yep. Got it. So the moment the father
moves, the son is moving at the same
time with the spirit. That's his point.
I can't help but work because I can't
help but do what he does whenever he
does it in the same way he does it. That
is a claim that no creature can make. If
everyone got the point, that is a claim
no creature can make.
But they didn't believe that cuz they
saw a man. They were not seeing God.
They saw a man, but they didn't know
this was God as a man in the flesh. All
right. Now, what I'm going to leave you
with this final point. What I'm trying
to get at all this one hour rant that I
gave you was to show you. Jesus did not
debate for the sake of debating. Jesus
did not engage people who are
argumentative, stiff necked, hardened,
and blasphemous. He rebuked them. He
insulted them. He belittled them. He
shamed them. and he drove them away
because they had proven that they're
dogs who are resistant to the truth.
Matthew 16:104, the Pharisees and sad
Jesus came to Jesus and tested him by
asking him to show them a sign from
heaven. Remember, he had shown them sign
after sign after sign after sign and
they're still not satisfied, right? And
what was the pattern? No matter how many
signs he showed them, still not enough.
Still didn't believe but double down,
right?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So what did Jesus say to them? He
replied, "When evening comes, you say it
will be fair weather, for the sky is
red, and in the morning today will be
stormy, for the sky is red and overcast.
You know how interpret the appearance of
the sky, but you cannot interpret the
signs of the times that the king of God
is upon you." So, look what he calls
them, a wicked and adulterous
generation. By the way, I'm going to
show the recedes that the Aramaic word
that I found, Syriak, is a very, very
graphic translation of the Greek because
it means a pimp. someone who pimps
people. But anyway, I'm still trying to
confirm that in one of the additions
uses the word. But anyway, a door to
generation looks for a sign, but none
will be given it except the sign of
Jonah. Jesus left them and went away.
Did he entertain them?
>> No, he left them and went away.
>> Did he give them a sign?
>> No.
>> Did he try to engage them theologically
and have a debate?
>> No.
Did he insult them and call them wicked
and adulterous?
>> Yes, sir.
>> You with me there?
>> Did he insult them?
>> Yeah.
>> You sure?
>> All right. Now, what does he say to the
Pharisees here? Okay. Listen. Woe to you
teachers of law and Pharisees, you
hypocrites. He called them hypocrites
here, right? You shut the door of the
kingdom of heaven in people's faces.
Yourselves do not enter. So he said,
"You're not going to enter. You're going
to go to hell." And you make everyone
else who follows you go to hell, too.
But here, I want you to see this. You
blind fools. The word fool, it's
You idiot. You
So, did Jesus do what you do? Engage
people and debate with people and argue
with people that double down and refuse
to accept correction or refuse to see
Because these people thought Jesus was
wrong. He is fake. So what did Jesus do?
Insult them, belittle them, sent them on
the way or just left them here. In this
case, who walked away from them? Let's
see here. Matthew 16. When he was done
with them, who walked away from them?
>> Jesus then left and walk away.
>> So who walked away from them?
>> Jesus.
So then if Jesus walked away and no one
can love people more than Jesus, why do
we think we can outlo someone, love
someone more than Jesus, out love Jesus,
and engage people that show they don't
want to